in the aftermath of a financial crisis
wayward banks were rained in a banking
Union for the eurozone was devised with
three course strands the european
central bank would supervise national
bank practices a mechanism to support
banks in trouble before they went bust
came into force in 2016 and the last
step still to be undertaken will try to
keep saving secure but has it been the
right medicine what I have been better
to create a new institution as a
European banking supervisor that would
have been the better solution but giving
it to the ECB is still better than the
fragmented national system we had before
where the member states were competing
for the weakest banking supervision
which was one of the practice which led
us into that financial crisis during the
crisis bailouts with a norm but that
intent ballooned government dint now
us-style system is in place where
investors manage the risk we have to
avoid of course the unintended
consequences that baleen instead of
reducing risk and answering skin
turnover lack of confidence this
requires first banking Union is
completed so the deposit guarantee and
the backstop are crucial elements and
also that we use the baleen tool in a
proportion at the fairway but Germany
remains opposed to a deposit guarantee
system saying it redistributes risk
across the EU negotiations are ongoing
Oh